why do you like index why are you hyped
for index because here's my opinion I
don't get it it's so it's it's not bad
it's just really mediocre and that's my
opinion in index this was me literally a
month ago reaction to the new index
season 3 trailer as I was streaming my
impressions of the fall season charts
see the whole index rail gun to arrow
whatever you want to call it franchise
has always been somewhat of a mystery
for me from my perspective it always
looked like your typical generic high
school fantasy action light novel that
has been done a million different times
nowadays and any attempts to watch the
anime did nothing to prove me otherwise
yet it's the franchise I had one of
those fan bases that were praised it to
high heavens you know one of those rabid
fan bases that seems nyeon obsessed
would have franchise and would take any
opportunity they had to spread the word
of the holy gospel like they were
recruiting for a new religious cult or
something so after seven years of
silence before new season getting
announced seemingly out of nowhere I
said you know what [ __ ] it I'm going to
try to get to the bottom of why this
franchise is so beloved by so many
despite by my accounts it looking like a
dated the mid-2000s generic light novel
franchise that time should have left
behind and through that journey I
discovered a unique world that blends
fantasy and science in a way I'd never
seen before a grand narrative that fits
the bill for a shared universe I had
been searching for an anime for so long
a power system so intriguing you tested
my knowledge of my university education
that's before I knew it something
happened I became a fan
[Music]
index has become my newest obsession and
sometimes there's nothing quite like the
feeling of completely losing yourself in
the franchise consuming every little
thing it has to offer researching the
intricacies of the world mechanics
finding every little bit you can about
the law and background and you do it
because the deeper you go the more
rewarding the experience becomes as a
whole this franchise was exactly that
for me so today I wanted to share some
of the reasoning why I got so sucked in
to the world of index now before I get
started I wants to give a quick shout
out to book Walker who are doing an
index giveaway right now if you want to
win some figures details are coming at
the end of this video if you feel like
having a dabble with the franchise
because I understand that as big as
index was in its heyday it's been seven
years since its last anime adaptation so
I'm sure there are many of you now who
have not even heard of the franchise so
here's a bit of background a certain
magical index is a light novel series
that started in 2004 and has since
spawned the grand franchise Fault in
multiple anime adaptations spin-offs in
mangas and animes and lots and lots and
lots of light novels many people are
familiar with the franchise through its
main line anime series a certain magical
index in which we mainly follow a spiky
haired protagonist Tomac Armijo on his
adventures of fighting magicians picking
up chicks and solving literally every
problem by punching in the place but
arguably equally as popular is its
spin-off series a certain scientific
railgun which focuses on The Adventures
of Mikoto Misaka a powerful ESPO with
the ability to control electricity shrug
off teleporting lesbians and has
basically peaked you as a tsundere anime
girl from that brief description it may
be hard to see the appeal of index
because that's what it looks like from
the outside and to say the franchise is
a bit daunting is kind of an
understatement at this point but for my
personal experience through all the
confusion about the sheer scope
explanations about chronology you've
read and watch order I never really saw
anything to explain to me what the core
appeal of Enix was and why it's a mass
such a loyal fanbase so that's what I'm
gonna try and do today and I think a
good place to start instead of
explaining specific plot details is to
start explaining what index is as a
concept
[Music]
in next session a world very reminiscent
of the one we're in right now it said to
both magic and science play a massive
part in it
you have the world of magic which has
its roots and faiths and religion that
can be traced back through various myths
and legends and has shaped lots of the
world's history through secret
organizations and practices this is
where you see a lot of the traditional
fantasy elements with mages and
magicians drawing their powers through
spells and magic and it finds his basis
through a lot of real-life law we can
find in this world however you'll serve
the world of science as the main setting
is the modern sci-fi world of Academy
City here you have a city that's
advanced to be 30 years ahead technology
wise to what we have today and it's full
of people who have gained supernatural
power through the practices of science
and experimentation and while both these
worlds are normally kept separate they
are in conflict with each other both
vying to be in the dominant power to
shape the world of index which serves as
the basis for the various stories told
in the setting and it's really hard to
get this perspective from the beginning
this is where a lot of the confusion
about what the franchise is about lies
many people myself included were only
really exposed through the plot synopsis
of the opening arc something about a
generic spiky haired boy who's right an
of the power to cancel out any magical
supernatural ability hashtag a weaking -
no not November running into some lolly
nun that has a load of magic books in
her head who's getting chased by this
mysterious magical organization with
your usual trashy power fantasy stuff
and while this is technically what
happens it's not an accurate
representation of the franchise at all
despite his name index is not actually
about index the lolly nan character nor
is it really about Toma despite him
getting most of the screen time a better
way to describe this series from a
broader perspective is that it's like a
shared universe with many moving parts
having more in common with things like
Game of Thrones or the Marvel Cinematic
Universe think of every story arc as a
different movie in the MCU each arc is a
self-contained story that has a new
elemental cast of characters to the
world whether they focus exclusively on
the science side of things or the magic
side of things and occasionally you gets
bigger crossover events that involve
every party where you get to see the
normally separate carson elements come
together because of this structure you
can have multiple storylines running in
parallel and sometimes you get to see
the same events happen but from the
different characters perspectives and
while not every story arc is essential
to follow along with the ground and
narrative they all add something to the
Canon of this shared universe so while
all the different series stretched
across
multiple mediums may look confusing and
daunting what it really means is that
there are multiple ways to get into this
franchise you can start with index or
you can even start with railgun if you
so please you can read the light novels
for some arc and switch to the manga
then switch to the anime or vice-versa
it doesn't really matter how you choose
to consume it because the universe that
you'll take place in stays coherent the
only difference is that law novels may
go more in depth than the intricacies of
the world and their systems this is why
I has it's called railgun a spin-off
because while technically the events
aren't as important to the main
narrative in the same way that for
example black panther doesn't move
forward the grander Infinity stones
plotline of the MCU it's a great story
and serves to give the viewer a better
understanding of the characters and why
they act the way they do in the main
series in Nexus core appeal stems from
this expanded universe and how
extensively it blends in it's science
fiction and fantasy elements in a
coherent world I've made a video before
expressing my desire to see some kind of
shared universe and anime form and I
didn't realize at the time how closely
index fitted this bill because for all
you can say about the characters and
protagonists that make up the world as
good or bad as the characters maybe they
aren't individually what makes this
franchise what it is they are on what
drives as fan base to be as invested or
obsessed as they are it's the world
which is encompassed by setting Academy
City Academy City is a weird beast to
tackle because while it's technically
just a backdrop for all these story arcs
taking place I'd actually argue that it
is the main character of the franchise
because while Tomer may be the face and
main protagonist of index early on as
the world expands and more characters
get introduced index becomes the story
of Academy City itself it's the
inhabitants of Academy City whose story
lines we get to follow its Academy City
that is a driving force for the grander
conflict its Academy City which serves
as the core thread that connects all the
numerous plot lines together even if
events aren't happening there it always
exudes a constant presence and honestly
seems like a really cool and unique
place which unfortunately the anime
doesn't always do justice with a simple
betrayal or [ __ ] bad CG wind turbines
everywhere because of the amounts of
strange different happenings revolving
around this city the series can take
many forms and genres depending on the
Arkin character were following sometimes
it's a dark sci-fi involving horrific
human experimentation sometimes it's a
fantasy action exploring secret
underground organizations sometimes it's
a fluffy high school slice of life and
sometimes it's all
those things admittedly I found the
story arcs that focus on science far
more interesting than the ones that
focus the magic but what made it all
worth sticking through was when you were
able to see all the various characters
and plot lines converge some of my
favorite moments were actually just
seeing different characters from the
various story arcs meeting for the first
time in interacting with each other
there was a few episodes in index season
2 that was purely dedicated to [ __ ]
slice-of-life love involving all the
cast members and it was honestly some of
my favorite episodes the franchise
rewards you for investing in the world
as a whole with our elements you like
you have elements she won't like you'll
have characters that bore you and
characters that you absolutely love
which let's be honest is going to be
accelerated because he's best boy it's
the juxtaposition of all these different
narrative elements you wouldn't normally
see together put in one place that makes
it so interesting you not only have
majors and espers you have angels
alchemists on the ground assassins you
got modern military SWAT teams fighting
magical nuns and what I like is how much
they try to ground it in our world
because every element no matter how
ridiculous has a basis from our real
world supernatural phenomenon that we
may hear about here and there are given
an explanation in index with the rules
that structure that universe and that's
why this setting works this attention to
detail is something that's also mirrored
in their power systems which is the one
other big unique thing this franchise
has to offer
god damn I love the power system in this
franchise well half of it anyway because
most noteworthy is that there are two
entirely different systems that work in
parallel one for the magic side of
things and one for the science side of
things and both have been given a lot of
care to ground it in with elements we
can find in our own world the magic
system was a bit more confusing for me
but it makes sense in the law because
they are meant to be supranational
phenomena that cannot be explained or
analysed via any sort of scientific
means and reasoning so instead the basis
of magic in the index universe comes
from real-life mythology and law you can
find historically from Christianity to
Judaism to Norse and Egyptian mythology
to Feng Shui it all finds its roots
through stories towards reward history
and religion to give an example was
someone like Jesus in the index universe
would have been a magic user however to
me the standout power system comes from
the science side of things and that's
what I want to focus on because what
makes this stand out so much is how
grounded every ability is in real world
science and physics which you know if
something I appreciated heavily as
someone who went to university to get a
master's in electronic and electrical
engineering
I know this is a weird time to flex this
but I paid tens of thousands of pounds
for this piece of paper
let's take me sakha for example in
concept her ability is pretty simple she
can control electricity nothing new here
in the world of anime powers but it's
not so much the ability itself but more
so the logic behind its application has
the simplest level she can shock people
but thanks to my masters an electronic
and electrical engineering I know that
electricity has more applications than
just this and so the sheep because if
she can generate an electric current
that means she can generate a magnetic
force something you'd know if you
learned the right hand rule which is
what I did in my math is an electronic
and electrical okay so I'll stop this
now thanks for being able to create a
magnetic force you can stick to metallic
objects controlled a breed manipulates
iron fans and vibrate at a fast enough
frequency to make it a buzz saw let's go
even further what else can you do with a
combination of magnetic and electrical
force well you get something called a
Lorentz force and what can you do with a
Lorentz force well you can make a
[ __ ] railgun which is a real life
weapon our modern military has been
developing and if you couldn't guess
that's why the series is called railgun
the theory had so many layers to
someone's ability and thus your combat
strength doesn't necessarily come from
raw power but it's also your
understanding of science and physics and
how best to apply your ability and this
is something I found incredibly original
and made the science fights that much
more interesting but I think the one
character that really encapsulates just
how innovative these abilities can be
while still grounding it in real-world
physics its accelerator who has one of
the most unique abilities I've seen in
all of anime and no it's not his ability
to laugh like a beatboxing hyena
accelerators ability is vector
transformation now for those you who
didn't pay attention in maths and
physics and school a vector is any
quantity that has a magnitude and
direction and a hook is allegedly
explaining [ __ ] vectors in a video
about anime pretty much every force you
can think of can be broken down into
vector components an accelerator can
control the magnitude and direction and
what that means is any attack no matter
how big or powerful thrown at him he's
able to control not only the direction
but also the size of that attack read
the right hits back at his opponent or
anywhere that he pleases
the application of this ability goes so
far beyond that because so many things
have a vector component he can start
earthquakes by tapping his foot on the
ground he can block incoming sounds he
can control the wind he can manipulate
blood flow he can accelerate any object
just by poking at it if something has a
direction he can control it and what you
can do with this is only restricted by
your knowledge of vectors now I'm sure
you're thinking such an ability sounds
ridiculously overpowered because it is
so the limitations the author is given
around disability I feel are just as
smart because there isn't a limit to the
size of the force he can manipulate or
something but his limitations come in
get this mathematical calculations
that's right his kryptonite his [ __ ]
vectors can be complex mathematical
concepts to calculate and if you're
going to apply these manipulations in
the combat situation need to be able to
calculate how to do it in real time this
is exactly accelerators limitations he
has an on-board computer to assist him
with the calculations so if there's too
much data to process or the computer's
battery runs out that is his limit and
what he can manipulate and in my honest
opinion
that's [ __ ] genius because it
logically makes sense if such a
ridiculous ability actually existed in
this world which means if accelerators
ever in a bind there's only one thing he
can do in the face of overwhelming odds
I'm left with only one option I'm gonna
have to science the [ __ ] out of this of
course understanding the theory behind
these powers doesn't actually matter in
the wider context but for pretty much
anyone who comes from a scientific
background it feels incredibly rewarding
and it adds that extra layer to every
fight scene which is something I found
totally unique all right how many people
have I lost with that last section is
anyone still here engineers
mathematicians physicists anyone else if
you've made it this far all this sounds
exactly like your cup of tea well this
is the time when I start putting terms
and conditions to everything I've said a
lot of them
there is one thing I've lost over to
focus on the positive is an appeal of
this franchise and that is just how
goddamn hard it tries to put new people
off from getting into it remember when I
said I was put off by how generic and
boring the beginning arc seemed to be
well that still holds true and it can
still definitely be applied to a lot of
the early arcs in index the franchise
came at a time when trashy harem bates
high school fancied light novel
adaptations hadn't already oversaturated
the industry and going back through it
now it has really really not aged well
early index embodies almost all of the
Yogi's tropes character archetypes and
cliches we have gotten bored off since
this and they should release and it ends
up coming across as a run of the mill
was shown in action show considering how
much of it revolves around Toma he's
just not a very interesting character
and only gets development further down
in the light novel not only that but his
ability to cancel out other abilities
it's just so [ __ ] boring compared to
everything else I've talked about in the
franchise's power systems it's not bad
per se it's just extremely generic and
this is what makes it a really hard sell
I would like to say that you can easily
power through it and quickly get to the
good stuff and while there are
definitely some highs I'm going to touch
upon there is a lot of [ __ ] to wade
through entire seasons worth of episodes
mind you which in today's standards of
short hard-hitting 12-episode anime
series is probably gonna put off about
90% of you but this is exactly why
there's no such thing as a casual fan of
the franchise only those who've been
willing to trudge through all the
mediocrity are rewarded with everything
the world can offer and if you're
willing to do that that probably means
these elements I've talked about are
something that appeal very strongly to
you as was the case for me the good
thing to know is that while index season
one was mostly world building and season
two was a lot of build up to a climax
there was only just teased that by the
end those who have stuck with it are
finally getting to see a lot of the
payoff that is being adapted in season 3
that's airing right now and if you
continue reading the light novel it only
gets better and there's so much of it to
lose yourself in plus with a new season
of railgun and accelerator just being
announced there is no better time to get
into this franchise so after all this
there is one question left how do you
get into index index season 1 then
railgun then rail
s then index season - that's the short
version however that's a lot of episodes
and a big commitment if you're still on
the fence and quite frankly if I had
attempted that I would have never gotten
past the first season of index so I
wanted to share this streamlined method
I use that made me decide whether I
wanted to fully dive into the franchise
now I consumed it across different
mediums so if you don't want to do that
I will put the corresponding army
episodes manga or light novel volumes
on-screen if you just want to stick to
one this is Gygax guide to speedrunning
in this I starts off by reading the
first index arc via volume one of the
index light novel then I read the first
arc in railgun via volumes one two three
of the railgun manga then I watched the
anime railgun s which is basically what
sold me on the franchise I managed to
achieve this in a day so it didn't take
too much time and the reason I chose to
do this was I could quickly get an
introduction to the magic world and also
the science world while being able to
quickly go to one of the early
highlights that not only ties in a lot
of the main protagonists but is also a
great [ __ ] standalone story in its
own right in its best adaptation in
railgun s like I said you can get this
to the franchise whoever you want this
is just my method cuz I'm an impatient
prick or so this might be a good time to
mention that all the light novels and
manga are available via book Walker if
you want to try this method out hashtag
coupon code gig out for five dollars off
this is mode out - very daunting and
quite frankly hard franchise to get into
and will definitely not be for everyone
but getting into this franchise its
world and characters have given me a
completely unique experience in the 15
or so years I've been an anime fan and
that is not an easy feat to do anymore
if this seems like something way too
heavy to get into that's completely
understandable if you just want
something more quick and casual there
are many many other shows you can get
into but if the specific aspects I just
talked about sound exactly like
something you would appreciate and you
just want to lose yourself in a
franchise [ __ ] do it man become one
of us because I can see why this
franchise joins the ranks of things like
jojo's Montague Archer again fate for
having this really dedicated fanbase
that never shuts up about it because
there really is nothing else like it
hey guys I hope you enjoyed me
essentially just gushing over index for
almost 20 minutes I do want to give a
quick shout out to Brooke wall right now
who has the index light novels railgun
an accelerator manga if you want to try
it out they're actually doing a giveaway
right now we can win an index figure a
Misaka figure or a signed board by just
downloading a free sample of the index
light novel before November 30th plus at
the moment is 20% off or the railgun and
accelerator manga and you can use coupon
code Giga for another $5 off I saw the
pretty good deal in my opinion so get on
that before November 30th I'll include a
link below with the details so remember
to use coupon code Giga for $5 off any
purchase you make because if you want to
get into the franchise there's not a
better time than now anyway that's all I
wanted to say I've been gig ugh and I'll
see you all next time